you
these tournaments are so heavily stacked
I agree
there are a lot of tough guys on this
page okay here we go
snuck right up on me a daily hyper
bullet arena one hour
mana 30-second chess
play fast don't blunder stop d5 they
went there anyway
and just want to reorganize man can I do
that that's all I want to do is
reorganize
dark-squared bishop by winning now
I should be that's a queen and I'm going
for me
make it really simple this pawn around
keep him around cut their King off
oh man find a way man find a way white
to play in stalemate can you do it can
you do it like to play in stalemate I
wonder if you could find a stalemate
stalemate because you didn't have enough
material you clown oh man
you goof
just throw your ass fun why not
boy
just throw your F on
jeez
what did I do to deserve this oh hey
let's see - come on maybe you could win
this game
maybe maybe I'll take them now Oh ed
smothered mate I want to type at least
oh boy ok ok ok this is just too much
too much excitement to be a I don't know
you can't commentate in these hyper
bullets too difficult
I'll tech your night you react to me
they had a queen check I would have been
juicy alright just go caveman style
I'm in style
here we go I'm on b2 are you nervous are
you nervous here comes my knight watch
over smothered mates I'm setting it up
maybe
take him I got it I have to go here my
Kings in a aah
smothered mate town he took the bait he
took the bait
okay very important detail there that I
meant king went to the corner I needed
to be able to defend that a pink kettle
square space invader watch out
all right let's just launch pawns in
iPhones King why not that's a really
good development for my dark-squared
bishop love it he is loving D to open H
file open G file none of the above
I have a lot of space a trial going to
open up
um let's push
they're going to sack they're not
sacking
give me give me some open lines there we
go we're breaking this down oh yeah
I want to do that get over here well I
could just take that night dummy you
could have just captured that night
time burners were you out where the time
burners what's happening okay I got that
one
Oh after a stalemate start man
try an old Indian now I just dropped
upon and mouse slipped my clean to f6
you go on Queen side
back at the center
sky got'em dark-squared bishop it's
going to do do me any good they have
night here should they still have night
there 13 seconds you want to take that
night out take on c4 grab upon my king
needs to help oh my god
you
sneaky pawn oh my god point six eight
wow they're down on time they were going
to promote if I took the took the rook
there so I had to be fancy keep one one
piece around so they couldn't pre move
out only chess players know what that
phrase means pre move out don't allow
your opponent to pre move out you got to
keep a tricky Knight around or some
piece keep them on their toes whoo I
feel like I just ran a mile right there
you think it's just a thirty second game
but I ran a mile really I'm winded took
my breath away
ah okay put a knight in the center let's
just see if they take him oh boy I'm in
big trouble
I'm in very big trouble yeah I got to do
ugly stuff like this my Knights dead
my knight is dead
I just want to trade man I just want to
trade get rid of that knife that bishops
a killer
let's do Inbetweeners how's this working
out I got mates I almost fell from eight
on g2 oh I forgot that they had pressure
on g2 ah okay here we go
plenty of time left John wick again this
is the guy that I smothered mated maybe
maybe we get a back-to-back smothered
mate first time ever
remember that remember that time you did
it back-to-back smothered made against
John wick that's what I'm looking to do
here how can we pull off another
smothered mate is it possible sure why
not
why not who's the bad bishop who is it
tonight's coming for you I love any time
to pull that off or do I let's lock it
down my dark my light square bishop
needs to do something other than stared
his own pawns oh boy I didn't see it
opening up on that side oh I need help I
need help my Queens turning into pac-man
oh I just got my queen they drop their
queen they're down those gates do it
feds I quit 34 22 21 Oh
we're not even 10 minutes in whoo I need
a breather where's the breather bun I
need a breather sort of pause there
needs to be a breather button I think I
I put my voting for that once before can
we get a breather button where are the
breather buttons oh good fancy taking
advantage my own protected night well
done
you're clean strap though I didn't
calculate that it was a look what I
found move oh you lucky duck lucky duck
okay watch for a fancy rook here we're
going to double I don't know we're
cashing out now we're cashing out why
did I do that that was silly steak
there's a check cut back okay clean be a
pest where's the mate
ah they're being fancy and we're being
fancy get another queen there's no limit
no limit to the number of Queens you can
get nine back to tournament how it man
way too fast
I should have just pushed okay man
got the bishop pair
um let's just preserve that defend I'm
defending that right I still go there I
don't know
cannot explain it just going to get all
my pieces working night here's the
threat
was a threat okay my knight wants to be
on e6 he's almost there he's there
should just capture that pawn and they
resigned I still had a lot of time on
that one
so I was putting pressure on them I
guess with the pieces drifting over near
their Kings side I got to do that more
often this guy is super fast this Jacob
eight ah this guy is wicked wicked fast
I don't know what the ultra bullet
his ultra bullet rating is but he is
wicked fast wicked fast
okay all right in so many moves I'm
trying to get a Knight to f5 and now I'm
just going to sacrifice at some point
here we go
I want to take with the different piece
okay not sure to say so one King and
pawn in game they're being sneaky
they're being sneaky Wow
they do on a lot of shuffling but they
pull it off really fast and it's tough
to take them down that's been my
experience at least added like what ten
games in
seems like it okay I guess we're going
to get a flight square I do not like my
position I'm asking for trouble
yikes killed structure my knight on d5
maybe should have traded first
trade it first and
threatening mate got to get my king
towards the center ASAP it's a good move
okay is their night dead
not quite I don't have much time
yeah this one's gone this one is way gun
yeah
uh-huh can I do something fancy
I can't even say my king
that's the pack leader holy cow
lost potential new account for one
we have we have played many games okay
58 points that's a lot good performance
thus far all right let's launch the H
bond let's break this down a little bit
get some trades
okay we're ready to hit me with the fork
um yeah I got a complete development
here minor peace exchanges oh boy I'm
going to sacrifice there because I think
I have to
it's very dangerous right about now oh I
had their queen just take their queen
next time man take twice on that square
oh I got the Queen now oh why did I do
that
let's check run pond just get their last
pond run a pond else down mates
I'm afraid of stalemate I'm afraid of
stalemate
they're down on time oh why do I do this
to myself 43 minutes left of this oh boy
oh boy that's all you could say oh boy
we should before we take only only after
they have moved out bishop we try to be
disciplined even in hyper bullet try
they're lining up fancy stuff soon and I
imagine there's going to be an accident
over here it scares me
g6 oh boy oh boy pressure pressure
lots of pressure release the pressure oh
boy they have sacrifices here not
anymore they're throwing a lot of heat
at me a lot defend bishop defend I need
you here queen
that pond i got mate
I had mate
holy cow what a rat race Wow oh man
Trent tusks
oh okay this is a little too crazy a
little too crazy
Jeff animate a really drag hard here to
lose many as many pawns as I can can we
make this happen
can we make this happen
there we go this is a beautiful ending
for me beautiful ah
they took my rook they shouldn't have
done that cuz if I need you to say you
know I have a past pond I could work
with I have a passed pawn I have a
couple of them
no stalemates no stalemates get over
here take my pond
now stay all night
Nate whoo okay
41 oh boy I see Kaskaskia is in there
very odd player this Kaskaskia very odd
player very odd who knows why I'm saying
that it's just another terrible pun
I told cast that one time I said you're
very odd player only ever threes and
fives I had to say it I had to say it
then I had to describe what I meant
[Laughter]
we got a trade that's all I want
I insist I'm
just going to dance I returned returned
to dancing I got it
what I accomplished though more trades
oh now I'm really asking for it I'm in
big trouble
very big trouble you can't do that
oh I can't breathe
I can't break you that guy's fast loss
potential has paused using timeout oh
[Laughter]
man okay too much too much back and
forth I'm just I'm just a traitor
to traders off okay
tonight spins let's just take them oh
why they doing they're maybe going a bit
too fast still trying to adapt to the
hyper bullet speed
so check in there
my knight wants to be on a different
square let's go here there's a fork in
another Fork
not quite let's get behind him I could
pretty move this one out
they're down on time 78 43 is where I
stand 40 39 there's a lot of big guns on
this first page
oh boy lost potential again when I do
last time d4 let's try you for alright
we're going to try for this and make
life difficult for me to defend this guy
yeah let's stop g5 they might get
excited about that they might oh boy
I just dropped a piece again against
this guy maybe I build a Center yeah
they're not missing anything not missing
anything I'm dropping everything I got
to think more I got to think just a
little bit more
I got a pawn my opponent is going to
hurt me it's just out as they're going
to really really really hurt me oh boy
have much time
can they pull this off somehow
that rook
holy cow they haven't lost a game Wow
82 43 42 42 39 39 it goes all the way
down to eight and it's still anybody for
second place it seems first I don't know
someone could definitely still catch
first but
it's going to be difficult that is for
sure this is a very good line against my
silly system here against my silly
system they're weaving on in but I could
control this stuff maybe I should just
pick that pun up okay they're really
fast player I should not have captured
that pun I'm getting something now Wow
got to mop up these pawns fast
whoo oh man hmm
alex is doing very good he hasn't
dropped a game not even a well yeah no
loss just a draw thinking there
oh man Johnny DJ why man I needed to
keep this night around he's going to be
very important and he's gone just like
that sad to see you go night no I need
to keep some material around you know I
just need to keep some material around
okay maybe I get it f7 one day there's
going to be a queen trade I can't do
anything about it it's scary and that is
for sure
okay I got a piece back take that night
out huh
got another piece Oh No
holder down on time don't drop the piece
man you're going to have an easier time
if you don't drop a piece early on like
that within the first 10 most Wow
90 47 40 it's a race for a second it
seems I think Alec slipped up - yeah
he's he's been extinguished no fire for
Alex at the moment patience patience
this is the guy that put a lot of
pressure on me in this variation last
time a lot of pressure and they're
probably going to do some damage very
soon yolks
case in point right now I got to be
prepared to run be prepared to run King
to e7 let's go here right now
here
let's hang on to my knight whoa where'd
my tie on Oh discoveries discoveries Oh
where's the me I'm getting made it ah
man ha good one man good one they knew
they had me on time by a mile and a half
I got to change it up that that line is
very difficult to defend against in
these faster time controls
who even slower ones the pan of
Botvinnik attack
all right what do we do we try a French
defense
let's take what the pun and we're going
to try to attack my opponent how about
that here we're just going to go caveman
style
line up right here launch this guy
I'm going to break with I'm going to
break with this
just opens
a king is no longer there and that's the
problem one of them one of the problems
how to get that night out of there I had
their Bishop I have some some oh I
didn't want to do that
I was being sneaky there Wow 1.1
my goodness 98 49 48 also keep him yeah
I was just going to point out this guy
berserks
so this is 15 minute stuff or 15 seconds
it's insane insane
quick this guy can move very fast ah I
got a rip trade king upon ending how we
doing now pawn is a good guy right here
he allows me to win this King and pawn
him game he's the MVP I'm faster
I didn't calculate it but it's working
out through downtown
kept up with them in that one
very fast that's a that's a 48 mind you
with a hundred percent berserk oh okay
what do i do what do I do an open
Sicilian d5 is very unusual okay
struggling to to do stuff here
there's just Bishop there I need to
blockade I want to get my majority going
I have time to pull this off just
throwing these quick jabs at me why not
why not
oh I didn't want to do that it's a bad
mouth lip very bad they're giving me
some material Wow
oh man they're so fast they are so fast
okay 52 52 51 51 48 47 with 28 minutes
to go oh here's another speed demon wow
that's a pond I don't know why I'm
playing like this so you get away with a
lot though a lot if you didn't realize
you can get away with a lot okay
Queen trade preparing for okay let's
just stop that a activity they're going
to give me the - no time for that huh
Maine to trap maybe
oh they got a perpetual if they want le
dot scary
defense defense mm-hmm oh good okay Wow
I need a breather I need a breather I
got that one
strike at f7 just make one just make one
comment area now and that's it let's
just move on strike at f7 good
commentary on that game well done I
learned a lot that's that's what you're
here for to to learn to learn I learned
a lot watching you played hyper bullet
where can I get your mouse where'd you
get it where did you get it no I could
have captured my clean was in a pen
why am i trading like this I had me I
had me
I made again I stopped it I'm on the
rook sneaky
time burners
they did a time burner kind burner why
has lost potential stopped 64 55 54 Wow
being keto 1 2 3 oh man
25 minutes left a Sicilian no here we go
chip away at their Center let's keep
that adding counsel King said yet
reinforce my Center I could do this but
I don't want to just yet
now I want to okay let's push this guy
who gave me that guy where's the mate
making one
okay I still don't make one threat just
don't drop your queen for nothing all
right
that was pretty clean 102 73 5956 ninja
kiwi this is another speed demon
what's the I'm not sure what the ultra
is ultra Bowl rating is ultra bullet by
the way is 15-second chest that is a
time control
play that on stream or did a video that
is a bishop winning a lot of stuff here
a lot of stuff and this should be
absolutely deadly absolutely deadly
should should be deadly okay why is this
game continuing
why finally so you don't have to prepare
that move ultra bullet
okay back to tournament 102 78-63 58 56
56 54 53 51 41:49 look at this top page
does it go further page 2 it's just as
close Wow
okay get that e-pawn to flinch he's not
flinching I don't want a Castle kingside
they have some space let's throw the H
bone Adam
continue continue Oh their King should
feel very very very scared extremely
scared I'm scared right now
I got defend and trying to go here I'm
the one who's scared now oh why they do
that
where's my time where is my time defense
Oh where's the defense
you
I don't know
spotted that really don't
could have captured that rook
no oh I'm down on time oh I had oh man
they threw one one jab at me on e6 ah
man could I have just ignored that
somehow I'm gone after their king I
ripped their heart others their
structure their ah okay this is crazy
Cass crazy Cass
okay
trade maybe
on that pond huh they slipped up I think
pushing through now just have to watch
for tricky stuff watch out for tricky
stuff I could take because it's wits
check
Wow Wow Wow
that's all I could say you're just going
to hear a lot of clicking click click
click click click and then a wow it's 20
minutes to go 102 78-66 okay this guy
slapped me around last time let's try
this capture mix it up play with the
different structure okay there we go
just just shove pawns that's all
just keep shoving pawns tsunami of pawns
tsunami where's the mate I have a mate
anywhere um I have a lot of space a lot
of space that's a check finding me I
have that yeah I kind of missed that one
yeah I promote
you
draw I'll take it I should have timed
burn through my queen in the corner
that's the kind of tricks you have to do
sorry Queen the corner at that that
would shave off 0.7 seconds no problem I
had this guy's insane this guy's insane
here we go
easy does it kill your structure who
cares about it
all right there bishops really good
let's get rid of them we go here my
knight wants to be on f6 Queen trade
straight on my structure yes
at nights close to trap now let's get
rid of them
let's make a break let's hang out of
that
Brook is stuck time burners
I was going to attack the rook on my
next move okay
hmm 17 in change her age tilt let's go
with something simple oh thank of the
knight in d5 and start attacking maybe
you could attack once in a while oh I
can't take that Bishop f5 hit him with a
pin who's in a pin now who's in a pin
alright I got it
they're going to give I'm going to bring
the pain here it's not so clear the
other night is kind of in a pickle huh
just a little bit of a pickle let's try
this there we go that's a good move be
sneaky is being sneaky there it's being
sneaky there not any time oh boy life is
difficult
oh boy
oh man Alan was tough 88 74 74 armed and
try to get the third here I'm six out
from third 16 minutes to go
any one of these guys could still catch
me the insane chess player again hmm
doesn't get any easier that's for sure
alright I am a fan of having that Bishop
bite on that pawn
let's just build up continue to build up
now we have enough prep here let's
secure this box out there Knight improve
my knight pressure on d6 they're giving
me up on I'll take this guy get another
Knight into e v c6 forks
I could take this first then here then
push them on the night let's just pile
up now I'm crashing through on f7
pressure on the night let's get a trade
I get the night if they take
let's check let's take here let's push
this pawn he's promoting they resigned
back to Turman Wow hmm I got 70
in seventh
okay I guess this is Cillian is this the
guy that I I thought I had a good
position against last time I think so
they're playing similar let's stop at
five and this this time around okay
they're going to let me capture here
again okay light square bishop exchange
yeah here we go
Oh bishop here you dummy
I had bishop there oh they're in a
serious pin right that's pretty serious
isn't it take the knight take the bishop
take the knight first get rid of this
guy
no may end the game man
clean g2 72 I have fire this next one is
important I got to get up 76 it's tough
to string these games together pop pie
okay I'm going to take with the epon
against mr. pot pie I'm not sure what
that's doing it's just asking for
trouble it's just asking for trouble
clean exchange huh I got to do something
super ugly
and all yeah this is going to hurt this
is going to hurt real bad I have I have
connected pastors though it's going to
it's going to all be good it's going to
all be good my night kind of holds
everything together I think they're
being fancy got to keep that tricky
night around I've got to keep that
tricky night around
holy cow point three eight I can't
breathe
102 85 now 103 Cass has taken over this
guy Oz and never came back
holy cow it doesn't get any easier Alex
on board
what's with Knight to c3 that's
different
that is definitely different mass
exchanges and I guess we'll take and be
in some trouble oh boy
can I get some trades hmm what so let's
kick this guy way mass exchanges and
take care first I want to keep some
pieces on even though I have a horrible
structure I hope that that pawn can lock
down and some stuff gonna hope hope just
hope just
oh man I'm in trouble I'm down on time
ah man he's up there third - he's one of
them that I would have to overtake I'm
13 back 1040 hmm
Everest and I have to get a streak again
it's so far off let's kick him away
alright we're going to launch ponds at
my opponents King that's how we have to
do it I should have just played to h3
straightaway now that huh
so much for my attack okay I get a pawn
back maybe yeah it looks like it I want
to stop Knight to c4
so b3 and then reposition my knight my
knight wants to be on f5 there he is
discovered tricks I got the rook and
upon give a check first get rid of that
night they resigned back determine
stroll pawns at the enemy King 78-77
okay 93 86 78 what am i back too much 15
here's another monster he likes the this
player likes the King side fiend cutout
yeah let's throw some pawns Adam why not
continue we're sacrificing
we are sacrificing oh and see that they
could take there
oh this is going to fall fast I'm on the
Queen I am on the Queen they're thinking
this one through at least I'll do I have
a mate I guess I had some kind of mate
there yeah I was threatening Queen takes
Knight glad they pause there let's still
go here
Wow
oh boy I got the W I have some fire
Alex slipped up 84 8 minutes to go
that's 8 games
gotta get this next one very important
84 I need an 84 all the pack leader yes
this is the pack leader yeah so fast so
fast I should be able to control this
oh my god
Oh
can't breathe when I play that guy's so
fast he is so fast and that's on a
berserk man that is on a berserk try
that try playing 15 second chests crazy
crazy crazy
no this guy is smacked me around the
last two times
the last two times he's looking for a
hat trick okay got to take that material
back man
chest basics
okay here got a pre move a bit more huh
oh man why why do this throw punches
throw punches oh I can SIG's AG zigzag
technique that burned a lot of time yeah
is the zigzag technique remember that
one it's good okay um okay we're going
to try to work on the e5 square
overtook it centralized centralized
defend take a night out when he arrives
in the center defend mate it's important
isn't the bishop cooked he's cooked he
is cooked we trade
steak with the knight centralize the
night I got a rook gotta stop these
pawns before they kill me
plenty of time you could do it you could
do it just keeps our own threats punches
no stalemates take my rook no stale
Knights Nate back to terment where do we
stand for ninety to ninety seven ninety
to ninety one ninety eight whoa I might
have a chance for first if I if I could
win these next four and I realize
okay we're getting first how about that
we're getting first
come on you're getting first that's the
plan that's been the plan all along
I just forgot that it was possible see
what happens I forgot it was possible to
get first shame on me shame on me it's
scary careful isn't that a clean hit the
Queen where's the me oh my god I got
mated Oh what am i doing anything but
that they had only two seconds left ah
man that was so easy to win I found a
way to lose I could have done anything
there anything ah man
my hopes are gone the final four I don't
think I could win anymore
yes you can somehow oh man my opponents
having way too much fun right now
too much fun
threw down on time where am I at 94 ah
what would I've had 96 and then a
hundred I would have had a hundred at
this point
ah that one was a killer a killer okay I
get rid of this guy and then going for
me that's the plan
g5 let's do it over here incoming g5
what's that about let's hit it with a
fork
where are the forcing moves
let's take here no I'm getting made it
again in beautiful fashion this guy
smacked me around those last two games
ah man I don't think I'm going to get
another pairing out ah those were two
killers
that was a double checkmate by the way
that last one and that's how it's going
to end on a double checkmate no ah you
never want a tournament to end on a
double checkmate now but that's what
happened what can you do the tournament
pairings are now closed
316 or in this one ooh if this guy
finishes alex is going to get first that
game's over now
yeah it's mate final standings just out
of podium land Kaskaskia 110 Astana
chess 109 lost potential 102 and I was
in there at 94 but it was anybody's game
for well it was really close all right
for a hyper bullet mmm so close so close
I had my chances right at the end you
have to finish strong and I did not okay
to the 315 of you could games all
whoo tough tough tough